-Jonas Brothers!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Hey!
-Sup!
-This is called
Quarantine Confessions, alright?
-Now, before the show,
we all submitted
one or two confessions
of embarrassing things
we've done during quarantine,
and I have them in this jar.
-Oh.
-I'm gonna read them one
at a time,
and we'll try to figure out
who wrote it.
If it's your confession,
you have to bluff
and make us think
it's someone else.
-All right.
-These are all totally true.
-Sounds good.
-Alright, here we go.
"I talk to my dog
like it's a real person."
-Ooh.
-Hmm. That's...
I mean, that's got to be Joe,
I think.
-I actually think it's Nick.
-It's...
-Does Nick have a dog?
-He does.
Gino the German.
-It's definitely Nick.
-And Diana.
-He got a new dog,
and I think, you know,
when you have a new dog,
you want to
get to know that puppy
a little bit better.
-Yeah, you also just got
a new dog.
-Just got a new dog.
-Look who's talking.
-Like two days ago.
Your dog is actually newer.
-True.
-Your dog's newer, and your dog
apparently is very talkative.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, actually, wait a second.
-This also could be...
This also could be you, Jimmy.
Couldn't it?
Could be.
-I mean, it could be.
I mean, sure.
-Didn't think about that.
-Do you think that would be
my quarantine confession?
I mean, I've had my dog
for a long time.
-I think you're more creative
than that.
-Yeah.
-I think it's Nick.
-[ Laughs ]
He's got a good poker face
if it is Nick.
-I'm not doing myself
any favors here,
but I don't think that's
a bad thing.
-It's actually not a bad thing.
I think it's totally normal
and everyone should
talk to their dogs to feel --
-It's Nick! It's Nick!
It's definitely Nick.
-It's definitely...
[ Laughs ]
-Do you really just talk to your
dog like it's a person, Nick?
-Yeah. Yeah, I will admit that
I didn't realize I was doing it
until the other day, and I had
a real moment where I said,
"This has gotten out of hand.
This is..."
-How long was the conversation?
-It was like 20 minutes.
-[ Laughs ]
-Working through some things.
-That's pretty weird, man.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, guys, here we go.
Quarantine Confessions.
"My biggest decision
each day
is if I'm wearing sweatpants
of jeans."
-Mm.
-I think it's Kevin.
-That's got to be Kevin.
-Kevin's got a jean jacket on.
-Yeah,
are you wearing jeans?
-You might be wearing both.
-Could be wearing, yeah,
jeans over your sweatpants.
-Mm.
-It is definitely a thing
to figure out every day,
but, you know,
it's nice to --
-What does the lower half
of your body look like?
-Might be the lower half of your
body is like a horse.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes. It is.
I do have jeans on today.
-I don't wear sweatpants.
I'm not a sweatpants guy.
-Me either.
-I never was.
But I...
I don't know.
I found a few that I really
connected with
over this last seven weeks.
-Connected with.
-Sweatpants, that is.
I'm talking to my sweatpants,
as well.
It's a whole situation.
-Yeah. That was actually
a big point of, like,
fight with me and my wife
for a long time.
Like, I would never wear,
like, comfy clothes until, like,
right before we, like,
went to bed.
And it was...
She was like,
"I don't understand this.
You're in your jeans
constantly."
-It's got to be you.
This is such a big dilemma.
-Yeah, it's a big deal for you
in your household.
Obviously, it's you.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm gonna go with Nick,
actually.
-It could definitely be Nick,
-I think it's Nick.
-No one's pointed the finger
at Joe at all
and made him say anything,
really.
-Joe's a shorts guy.
Everybody knows it.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
He is a shorts guy.
-Yep. [ Laughs ]
-Alright, I'm gonna go
with Kevin
'cause he's wearing
a jean jacket.
-I'm going with Kevin.
-It's Nick.
-What do you think?
Well, who is it?
-It's me.
It's actually me.
-I think it's --
Oh, it's Nick?! Oh!
-What?!
Oh, my gosh!
-I told you. Two in a row.
-I'm sorry. Kevin, I'm sorry.
I should have --
-It's okay.
You underestimated my ability
to look presentable every day,
but it's fine.
It's cool.
-No, no, no.
I would never think...
You always look presentable.
Nick, are you wearing
sweatpants now?
-I'm wearing pants right now.
I could show you if you'd like.
I'll send you a picture later
of my pants.
-[ Laughs ]
I'll add it to my collection.
-Alright, so far,
that's Nick.
So it feels like none
of these next three,
none of these could be Nick.
It's either Kevin or Joe or me.
-Ooh.
-We have three left.
But, Nick, feel free
to play along.
"I forgot to wear pants to my
first Zoom meeting of the day."
-Yeah, I'll tell you what,
it's not me
because I don't feel like
you have to wear pants
on Zoom meetings, so...
-Ooh, that's a good bluff.
It's not me because
I'm constantly standing up
and doing stuff,
so I have to wear pants.
-Ooh.
Just in case.
-Yeah, I mean, yeah, 'cause
the show's constantly taping.
I tape the show all day.
-Oh, okay.
-I want to go with Joe.
-Well, Kevin, quickly,
why wouldn't it be you?
-Because, I already have
a battle with whether
I should wear pants
or sweatpants every single day,
so not wearing them
would not be one of my things.
-Nick, you want to weigh in
at all?
-That was not a convincing
argument, Kev.
I'm gonna go with Kevin
on this.
He looks nervous.
He's sweating.
I could see it through
the Zoom.
-Yeah, I can kind of see it
a little bit, too.
His face is getting red.
-I'm definitely sweating.
This is very dramatic
and intense, and I, you know...
This might be the reason
the band breaks up again, Jimmy.
So we have you
to thank for that.
-Yeah, thanks a lot, man.
-Yes, it is me.
It is me. I did forget
to wear my pants
the first day I had
a Zoom meeting.
-Knew it.
-It's true.
-That was a good one.
Alright, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
"I secretly love watching
'90 Day Fiancé'
over my wife's shoulder."
-Ooh.
-Poker glasses there.
-Poker glasses.
That seems like a Joe thing.
-It definitely does.
-Why?
-Because we know that Sophie --
-'Cause none of use television.
-Well, no, no, no.
Over his wife's shoulder,
which we know Sophie's obsessed
with reality TV,
as is Danielle, though.
-Correct.
-So, it's not mine,
so it can't be me.
You guys, like, don't...
And, Nick, like, you guys
don't really watch TV, so...
I vote Joe.
-I'm not a big...
We're more movie people.
We're not TV people, you know?
-It's not me for sure because
I absolutely love that show.
And whatever, so...
It's Joe.
He put the glasses on
right before the question.
-Yeah, it's me. It's me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well done.
-Easy.
-It is a great show, though,
right?
-It's really good.
It's really good.
-It's unbelievable.
It's a great show.
-I felt like that my wife
got me into reality TV.
That's all we're watching.
I'll just read the last one,
'cause it's me, just for fun.
This really happened, but,
I ate a pint of ice cream
in my sleep.
-In your sleep?
In your sleep?
-Here's what happened.
I was really tired,
and I went to bed,
and I brought up a pint
of Ben and Jerry's.
And I brought two spoons.
One for me, and then,
my wife,
when she eventually came to bed,
I'd share it with her.
And I fell asleep,
and I woke up the next morning,
and the pint was empty,
and I go...
And I remember having some,
I was just tired, and I woke up,
I go, "Honey, that's awesome.
You had some ice cream
last night?"
She goes,
"I didn't have any ice cream."
And I go,
"Well, I brought two spoons.
They're both used."
She goes,
"I think one fell on the floor."
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
-The days are too long
or short or something,
but I'm trying to get
a schedule back on, but...
And I'm just so lucky
I'm still married.
Guys, let's get into
an interview when we come back
with more "Tonight Show."
I'm talking to
the Jonas Brothers!
Whoo!